all right joining me now two people who
worked on the independent council with
Ken Starr and Saul Eisenberg of course
they're both foxnews contributors and
joining me kevin brock who was appointed
assistant FBI director for intelligence
by muller and house freedom caucus chair
mark meadows all right Ken
what was Muller's biggest for lack of a
better word screw-up today
total lack of preparation or at least
the inability for whatever reason to
communicate to show mastery or really
basic knowledge of the report so I was
stunned and then I was shocked by Bob's
inability to focus to show that he
understood the questions the constant
please repeat the question sometimes you
do that as a witness to stall and gather
your thoughts but it seemed to be
genuine what was that question so there
there was he was in a state of befuddle
month which became I think embarrassing
and then I just say early on I was so
glad to see that the issue of
exoneration of the idea of a prosecutor
taking it on himself or now we know the
team taking it on themselves the Muller
team to say this report does not
exonerate the president and we've been
saying this for several months now
totally inappropriate totally improper
and now we know Laura that is much more
likely than not something that Bob
Muller did not in his judgment come to
it was the judgment of the Muller team
yeah mark man doesn't want to go to you
now if the office of Ken's point we're
gonna move to this because he was asked
about who appointed him right at this
hearing and for those of you who missed
this watch which President appointed you
to become the United States attorney
from Massachusetts which Senator which
president which president I think
President Bush according to my notes it
was President Ronald Reagan had the
honor to do so under who's it my mistake
Congress I mean it's look the
president's been through hell his
family's been through hell
Carter page all these people that we
don't talk about every night had to hire
lawyers they had to go through all this
testimony they were vilified called
treasonous and everyone built him up to
be this guy and we cut my sound bite
down but who walked on water right I
didn't buy it from the beginning
any time the elites build up someone to
this demigod status might antennae
always go up I'm sorry maybe the nicest
nicest guy in the world this was a sham
from the beginning he was not with it
and he's running this investigation that
could affect us geopolitics right I was
right there next to Bob Muller for the
entire judiciary hearing and it was
obvious that he was not prepared and
that he didn't have a grasp of the basic
facts of this investigation right I mean
you know more about the investigation
this whole panel knows more about this
investigation then Bob Muller doesn't
after today that's what we it was very
alarming and and that was meant to be a
softball question by a Democrat and you
know it was a swing and a Miss and it
was just a sad day you worked with him I
did you've know him I assume you think
he's a man of great integrity your view
I do indeed but I got a lot of text
messages and tweets from from colleagues
and the operative word of the day seems
to be painful it's not the Bob Miller we
remember but we all those of us with
white hair you know we lose a little bit
of verbal dexterity over the years but I
think his basic unfamiliarity with the
report itself having to pull along his
deputy for backup
does not inspire confidence and his
answers today did not inspire confidence
that he was in command and control the
deputies seem like caretakers okay I'm
gonna say it and Billy said oh you know
this is the US presidency involved we
were led to believe that this was their
gonna be the best of the best the
fairest of the pharisee and it wasn't it
wasn't Saul you have been a big defender
of Muller from the beginning you've
never worked with him but after today
your thoughts well
been a big defender of his integrity
from the beginning and I still am a
defender of his intact okay we'll get to
that I'm not gonna have I'm not gonna
kick him when he's down like Kevin I got
text messages from people out of the
blue people haven't talked to ex-fbi in
years saying literally this is not the
Bob Muller that I knew something is
wrong I don't know when that started I
do know that to me the failure today is
a failure of the Democrats this man said
the report speaks for itself
I don't want to say anything beyond
what's in the report and I think if he
had been much sharper than he was today
he still would not have given them what
they want to hear and when you do not
give them what they want to hear they
destroy you as they have been doing all
day and they are doing tonight as they
are merciless I can't I had a piece of
advice I offered on Twitter today I kind
of held my fire totally near the end of
the testimony but my advice was okay
committee when you want a really big
hearing and a lawyer that you're gonna
call really doesn't want to testify
you think he's gonna make your points
don't bring him to testify he said he
didn't want to testify and I think maybe
he knew he didn't know the underlying
facts we're gonna get to some of these
facts like the steel dossier in a moment
but he said he didn't want to testify
and Barr said basically in that letter
stick to the report he wandered off when
a few times when he wanted to when the
Democrats asked him some questions but
the Republicans it was like shut down
not gonna answer not going to answer
that question but he never wanted to do
this testimony Kim from what we know
this was just an enormous misjudgment
because there now that we look back
20/20 hindsight we now see some of the
warning signs his press conference where
he said no questions you know I think
it's fundamental to democratic society
that people who hold power as he did at
that time have to be responsive not just
to the Congress of the United States but
to the media so prosecutors have to be
careful about what they say but he had
issued his report so it was time to
to answer questions including the
questions that have been raised about
the integrity not about Mahler but of
his team and especially the political
leanings all that had been in the public
domain but he had never responded to
these I think very reasonable effect
powerful questions but he said I'm not
going to respond so I think that was a
telltale indicator a harbinger then of
what we saw today all right congressman
meadows I want to play this exchange
about the steel dossier this is what got
the whole investigation going for
everybody who's lived under a rock it
was this dossier through fusion GPS
compiled with supposed sources the
highest levels of the Russian government
all a bunch of phony baloney stuff paid
for ultimately by the Clinton campaign
this was the exchange about the steel
dossier when did you become aware that
the unverified steel dossier was
intended was included in the FISA
applications spiral Carter page I'm not
gonna speak to that your team
interviewed Christopher steel is that
correct not gonna get into that you can
tell this committee as to whether or not
you interview Christopher steel and a 22
month investigation with 18 lawyers as I
said at the outset that is one of those
one of the investigations that is is
being handled by others in the
Department of Justice you know it was it
was really that moment in one moment
before when he said he didn't know GPS
looked at both of those you know you've
been covering this obviously it's not
just you that's been covering it is it's
been all over for two years atom shifts
talked about it Devon Oona's has talked
about it and yet here we are with Bob
mower not being able to answer just the
basic questions of the genesis of this
entire investigation and and you know
you hit an earlier point here you know
the Democrats forced Bob Muller to do
this it was first that they wanted to
wait for the motor report and they got
the Ramola report and then they wanted
him to come back and they they wanted
him to do a press conference and then
they wanted him to show up three times
they've struck out now they're not going
to stop here they're gonna get Don began
they're going to try to continue to
pronounce his name
today hands why they're behind I mean
right now they are so behind they need
to just stop close the bed okay so it's
good for the country and Kevin this was
what Andrea Mitchell said about the line
of inquiry about the steel dossier it's
shameful shameful that Republicans were
so focused on trying to undermine the
origins of the investigation that they
did not deal with the fact that has been
concluded by by all of the intelligence
agencies under Obama and of course
they're professionals Kevin well this is
the gaping hole in the whole
investigation Bob Mahler was whole
handed a mandate to do a
counterintelligence investigation you
and I have talked about that and he ran
off and did a criminal investigation
ignoring a lot of the basic
counterintelligence questions that
should have been asked and one of them
surrounds the whole issue of the steel
dossier and and the Russian involvement
in that in their efforts through that
dossier to manipulate manipulate the
presidential election and so we learnt
today just how much the Muller
investigation was impacted by this
so-called obstruction that they of
course claimed it never actually
happened it wasn't affected at all watch
no no we're were you allowed to complete
your investigation unencumbered yes and
in fact he resigned as Special Counsel
when you closed up the office in late
May 20 2019 is that correct correct
congresswoman Lesko did this in like
three three questions saul was it
impeded wasn't fired finish the
investigation sometimes I'm critical of
the Republicans cross-examination
techniques I sometimes think they need
to bring in real pros like you to do the
cross-examination but that was great she
was fantastic well she was great but
everybody should have taken a crack at
that because night as you know a skilled
cross-examiner having been one yourself
we'll roll it out and ask 20 questions
you were allowed to talk to the White
House Counsel Don Magan on multiple
occasions you were allowed to see
extensive notes
involving conversations between Don
Magan and the president you were allowed
to question anybody you wanted to over X
number of people you were never did
anybody ever claim executive privilege
did anybody ever claim attorney-client
privilege you literally could have asked
50 or 60 questions like that and the
answer it would have been very effective
and the answer would write out nobody
nobody ever kept us from questioning
anybody except for the President himself
which everybody knows about that issue
and so I would have liked to have seen
excellent excellent point and Ken there
was another point that we were all
talking about before the show which is
we had all these Democrat players who
you know any of our law practices when
we take a case you do a conflict check
you know and it's like a pain in the
neck like do you ever meet this person
do you know anyone it's like the
conflict checks are laborious in law
firms well this is like a mini law firm
really important the special counsels
office you don't want any appearance of
conflict the let alone an actual
conflict this is the line of questioning
about Jeannie Rhee and struck etc watch
Andrew Weissman attended Hillary
Clinton's election night party did you
know that before after he came onto the
team don't know what I found that out
are you aware that Miss Jean Erie
represented Hillary Clinton in
litigation regarding personal emails
originated originating from Clinton's
time as Secretary of State
yes did you know that before she came on
the toe when did you first learn to
Peter Struck's animus toward Donald
Trump in the summer of 2017 you didn't
know before he was hired I did not know
that can do four basic conflict or
appearance of conflict checks for an
operation as important to the US
government Constitution frankly the
world as this team was you vet you do
your due diligence you ask the key
questions it sort of is there anything
as when you're being considered for an
executive branch appointment
confirmation hearings is there anything
that could be embarrassing to the prezi
United States and
so I think Bob or whoever was doing but
it should have been Bob Muller himself
should have said I need to know I'm not
asking you anything about your politics
I respect the First Amendment and so
forth but I need to know is there
anything in mind I think this is gonna
be by that definition of politically
charged investigation about your
background what you've done that could
prove embarrassing to the investigation
in terms of the appearance of
impartiality that was so important and
my word given the group of people he had
around him but of course he must have
known about Andrew Weissman's reputation
professionally which he continues to
stand for but he should have asked those
tough questions yeah I mean this is
basic did anyone do a conflict Rick
I know Saul's gonna have this well the
press that who did the conflict check or
the appearance or the do you have
anything the president the President of
the United States did he's been talking
about this for two years
when we look at this you know just the
basic items of credibility right when
you look at what Bob Muller said today
you go well gosh you you want to have a
fair and impartial group of prosecutors
that are going but that's why building
him up from the beginning as the
demagogue the greatest of the greatest
no one would question him because I said
this is Bob Muller you can't question
Bob well I know but I wasn't questioning
Weitzman or whoever was doing it he
delegated it was he more of a figurehead
Kevin in this investigation after you
saw this performance today was he kind
of the figurehead he came into the
office every day I don't know what he
did at the desk but he might have done
something but he didn't he did not know
anything
Gene Erie was his law partner at Wilmer
whether he was or it wasn't that's what
he projected today and that he was a
figurehead
and that's unfortunate because that's
he's a much more capable person than
that this is the Achilles heel of his
investigation there's the perception
that it was front-loaded with what
Democrats and he wasn't able to get
around that the perception of abject
objection is all on the podcast today
you and I talked about this but that
political morning consult poll that came
out shows that even more Democrats now
from April to today are saying that this
investigation
was not handled fairly the that
percentage has gone up 15 percentage
points so even among Democrats that not
that distrust is growing obviously all
Republicans thinks that think it was
unfair but so this is not going in a
good direction for the Democrats given
the time the effort the promises we're
gonna Don jr. is gonna be in prison and
most people are saying why let's get
going here let's wrap this up I think
most Americans actually have a sense of
what happened here number number one the
collusion / conspiracy / coordination
whatever you want to call it the
president is totally exonerated in that
number two on the what people call the
obstruction front he overreacted he did
some things that were not wise that
we're disturbing that he shouldn't have
done but there's probably not an
obstruction case here and if there was
he's the president and we can't indict
him so let's move on I really think in
some kind of sense most Americans think
that way and you're not going to move
the ball any any further Justice Holmes
once said what is it a page of history
is worth a volume of logic and the fact
is number one this isn't Watergate but
number two the Republicans control the
house in the first two years of Trump's
presidency and that means the Democrats
were not able to start issuing subpoenas
and to start building up the kind of
investigation that happened in Watergate
and that's just reality that's just
politics
congressman meadows Nancy Pelosi reacted
today and said this let's watch I do
believe that what we saw today was a
very strong manifestation in fact some
would even say indictment of this
administration's cone of silence and
their cover-up this is on this is about
our soup the oath we take to protect and
defend the Constitution
someone yeah I don't know what she was
tuned into but she's using the word
indictment get your to your point
defense points all Kevin they're not
letting this go the language is for 2020
this is all that's all this was that's
exactly what it was a 20/20 hearing and
it it had no basis and trying to get to
the underlying crime which I believe is
how this whole investigation started
that's what Bill Barr and that's what
John Durham this cannot happen to
another president I could not happen to
another president cannot be done panel
thank you very much for being here
tonight